I have a confession to make.
I’m an addict.
Wow, that’s a load off.
Yeah, finally the world knows...that I’m
addicted to saying that I’m addicted to
stuff.
Hey everyone, Matt Lieberman here for DNews.
Self-diagnosis of addiction is rampant in
today’s society.
And I’m not talking about alcoholism, or
drugs, or anything substance-based.
I’m talking about phone addiction, twitter
addiction, facebook addiction, Chipotle addiction
- well, that’s obviously a real thing.
But are all of these diagnoses actually addictions?
Where does our addiction to addiction come
from?
Well, substance and behavioral addictions
are becoming more widely recognized as common.
Compulsive sex, shopping, and gambling as
reactions to stress are accepted as addictions
because of how the brain processes the cycle
of stress, compulsion, and reward.
In addition, and most importantly, the part
of your brain that inhibits these risky behaviors
are quieted.
However, when it comes to things like Facebook
and Twitter, no such quieting occurs.
The issue stems not from our ability to stop
ourselves, but from a lack of motivation to
do so.
AKA, it’s easier to check my notifications
than to delete my profile and potentially
miss out.
A recent study from Cal State Fullerton found
that only between 0.7 and 11 percent of the
people surveyed were “strongly impacted”
by the addictive tendencies that they displayed
concerning the internet and various internet
services.
Now the American Society of Addiction Medicine
defines addiction as “a primary, chronic
disease of brain reward, motivation, memory
and related circuitry.
It’s characterized by the inability to stop,
cravings, and most importantly, a lack of
recognition of significant problems with their
behaviors.
Namely, if you have the awareness to claim
addiction, you might not actually be addicted.
Additionally, we have to talk about the definition
of excess.
If someone plays World of Warcraft for 5 hours
a day, they obviously have a serious habit.
But if that person could not stop playing
to save themself, like a man in Taiwan who
died at an internet cafe after three straight
days of nonstop play, something more sinister
is obviously at work on a biological level.
Okay, so maybe we exaggerate when we say that
we’re addicted to poking people or crushing
those goshdarn candies, but what drives us
to do so?
According to Psychology Today, society has
an addiction to addictions.
The cycle is eerily similar to that of drug
addiction, namely, a new technology is introduced,
we overuse it to excess, and find ourselves
hooked.
When we stop using it, we go into withdrawal.
However, rather than go into recovery, we
label our overuse as an addiction to regain
some control over our behavior.
It’s not my fault that I can’t stop snapchatting,
I have a disease.
Hold on, that’d actually make a good snapchat.
Sorry, I’m addicted.
Our addiction to addictions and the rampant
over-labelling, not to mention the highs and
lows of watching people battle addictions
on television, are rewiring our neurochemical
impulses and pushing personal responsibility
further and further into the background of
our society.
But hey, it’s not our fault that we’re
irresponsible.
We’re just addicted.
Are you an “addict” who’s not really
an addict?
Fess up in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for more DNews every day of the
week.
And you can find me over at SourceFed.
Come say hi!